y calles convertidas en hospitales
algunos heridos son atendidos en
camillas o colchones debajo de los
árboles una de las zonas más afectadas
está en el sur del país específicamente
en la población de los cayos donde los
centros hospitalarios están colapsados
por el terremoto de 7.2 grados que
sacudió al país el sábado mientras tanto
miles de personas aún esperan ser
auxiliadas ayer fue un día muy difícil
porque había demasiada gente y no había
suficiente personal para atenderlos
teníamos a la gente que trabaja en el
hospital pero no teníamos personal a
pesar de que muchos se quedaron
trabajando hasta las 6 de la mañana sin
embargo manejamos bien la situación y es
lo que estamos intentando hacer hoy
también por los necesitados el país más
pobre de américa tiene una población de
11 millones de personas cuenta con más
de 900 instituciones de salud de las
cuales más de la mitad están ubicadas en
puerto príncipe donde reside el 35 por
ciento de la población pero en la zona
más afectada el número de instalaciones
sanitarias no dan abasto a la demanda y
son insuficientes
tiene muchos heridos muchos heridos se
necesita mucha asistencia y tiene muchos
muertos también
el senador de la calle está herido
también
se necesita mucha medicina en la calle
ahora mucha asistencia de las
autoridades de la comunidad
internacional de las ong de todas
los hospitales de las áreas más
afectadas ya estaban saturados y con
necesidad de refuerzos por los contagios
por el cob y 19 sumado a la crisis
política económica e institucional a un
mes y medio del magnicidio del
presidente de haití joven el mois además
el país caribeño sigue recuperándose del
terremoto que los azotó hace 11 años
mientras esperan la llegada de la
depresión tropical grave